what i want to do in this video is i
want to prove
i want to prove that segment ac
is perpendicular to segment db based on
the information that we have
in this diagram over here that this side
is it has the same length as that side
this side has the same length as that
side and i'll give you a hint we're
going to use one or more of our tr of
our congruence postulates i'll call them
i'll just stick with calling them
postulates from now on and so the ones
that we know so let me draw a little
line here this is kind of our tool kit
we have the side side side postulate if
the three sides are congruent then the
two triangles are congruent we have side
angle side
two sides and the angle in between are
congruent then the two triangles are
congruent we have asa
two angles with a side in between and
then we have aas two angles and then a
side so any of these things we've
established these are our postulates
we're going to assume that they imply
congruency and i'm also going to do this
as what we call a two column proof and
you don't have to do something as a two
column proof but this is what you
normally see in a normally an
introductory geometry class so i thought
i would expose you to it but this is
it's a pretty it's a pretty basic idea
is that you make a statement and you
just have to give the reason for your
statement which is what we've been doing
with any proof but we don't always we
haven't always put it in a very
structured way so i'm just going to do
it like this i'll have two columns
two columns write this like that and
i'll have a statement
i'll have a statement and then i will
give the reason
the reason for the statement and so the
strategy
that i'm going to try to do is it looks
like
right off the bat i can i it seems like
i can prove that triangle cda
is congruent to triangle cba based on
side side side and that's a pretty good
starting point because once i can base
congruency then i can start to have
angles be the same and the reason why i
can do that is because this side is the
same as that side this side is the same
as that side and they both share that
side but that i don't want to just do it
verbally this time i want to write it
out properly in this two column proof so
we have
cd
we had the length of segment cd is equal
to the length of cb
cd is equal to cb and that is given
that is given so these two characters
have the same length
we also know that da
this the length of segment da is the
same as the length of segment
ba so d a
d a is equal to b a that's also given
given in the diagram
and then we also know that c a is equal
to a c a i guess we could say so c a is
equal to itself and it's obviously in
both triangles so this is also given or
it's obvious from the diagram or obvious
from the diagram it's a bit obvious both
triangles share that side so we have
we have two triangles they have their
corresponding sides have the same length
and so we know that they are congruent
so we know that triangle
triangle cda triangle cda
is congruent to triangle c b a
to c b
c b a and we know that by the
side side side postulate and the
statements given up here let's actually
let me number our statements just so we
can refer back to this one two
three
and four and so side side side postulate
and
one two
and three statements one two and three
so statements one two and three and the
side side postulate let us know that
these two triangles are congruent
and then if these are congruent then we
know for example we know that
we know that that all of their
corresponding angles are equivalent so
for example this angle is going to be
equal to that angle so let's make that
statement right over there we know that
angle dce
so this is going to be statement five
we know that angle d
c e
that's this angle right over here is
going to have the same measure we can
even say they're congruent i'll say the
measure of angle dce is going to be
equal to the measure of angle
of
bce
b c e and this comes straight out of
statement 4. this comes straight out of
statement four congruency i could put in
parentheses
congruency of those triangles this
implies straight because they're both
part of this larger triangle they are
the corresponding angles so they are
going to have the exact same measure
now it seems like we can do something
pretty interesting with these two
smaller triangles at the kind of the top
left and the top right of this looks
like a kite like figure because we have
a side two corresponding sides are
congruent two corresponding angles are
congruent and they have a side in common
they have this side in common right over
here so let's first just establish that
here so i'll just write statement six we
have c e
the measure or the length of that of
that line is equal to itself once again
this is just obvious it's the same
it's the same
obvious from diagram it's the same line
obvious from
obvious from diagram but now we can use
that information so we don't have three
sides we haven't proven to ourselves
that this side is the same as this side
that de has the same length as eb but we
do have a side an angle between the
sides and then another side and so this
looks pretty pretty interesting for our
side angle side postulate and so we can
say
we can say by the side angle side
postulate we can say that triangle dce
triangle
dc
triangle d c
e d c e
is congruent
is congruent to triangle
to triangle bce and when i write the the
labels for the triangles i'm making sure
that i'm kind of putting the
corresponding point so i started at d
then went to c then to e so the
corresponding i guess angle or the
corresponding point or vertex i could
say for this for this triangle right
over here is b so i started if i start
with d i started with b c in the middle
it's the corresponding vertex for either
of these triangles so i put in the
middle and then they both go to e and
that's just to make sure that we are
specifying what's corresponding to what
and we know this
we know this is true by side angle side
side angle side and the information we
got from so we got this side is
established that these two sides are
congruent was from statement one
then that angle that these angles are
congruent is from statement 5
right over here and then statement 6
gave us the other side
statement 6 just like that and if we
know that these triangles are congruent
that means that all of their
corresponding angles are congruent so we
know for example that this angle right
over here is going to be congruent to
that angle over there so let's write
that down so we know statement number
eight
the measure of angle let's call that dec
d e c
is equal to the measure of angle b e c
b e c
b e c and this comes straight from
statement this comes straight from
statement seven once again they're
congruent congruency
congruency
and then we also know we'll make
statement nine
we also know that the measure of angle
dec
or maybe we should just write this way
angle
angle dec
and
angle bec
are supplementary
they are supplementary and that's kind
of you can just look at that from
inspection but i'll write a decent r
supplementary supplementary
which means they add up their measures
add up to 180 degrees and we know that
because they are adjacent
they're adjacent
and outer sides
outer sides form straight angle
form straight angle
straight angle
straight angle and then we can
essentially the next step if we know
that these two angles are equal to each
other and if we know that they are
complementary our next step means that
we would actually deduce that they must
be 90 degrees
so 10
measure of angle dec
equals measure of angle b
e c which equals 90 which equals 90
degrees and then for the reason it might
be a little bit more involved we could
put these two statements together so it
would be statements 8
and 9 and then statements 8 and 9 mean
that
d e c so i could write this measure of
angle d e c
plus measure of angle
of angle actually let me just since i
want to i don't want to do two too many
steps all at once let me just take it a
little bit by little bit
so let me just do it all
like this so let me say
measure
of angle
dec
plus measure of angle bec
is equal to 180 and this comes straight
from
point nine that they are supplementary
and then we could say statement i'm
taking up a lot of space now statement
11 we could say measure of angle dec
plus measure of angle d e c
is equal to 180 degrees and we know that
from statement nine we know that from
statement nine and statement eight
and statement eight we essentially just
took statement 9 and substituted that
bec the measure of bec is the same as
the measure of dec
and so then if we want statement 12 we
could say measure of angle dec
is equal to
90 which is equal to the measure of
angle bec
measure of angle bec and then this comes
once again straight out of straight out
of point number 11 and 8. and what you
can see i'm kind of taking a little bit
more time going a little bit more
granular through the steps and some of
the other proofs i've just said oh
obviously this implies this or that and
then we're done because if these are 90
degrees if these are 90 degrees so let
me write the last statement so statement
13 which is what we wanted to prove we
wanted to prove that ac is perpendicular
to db ac is perpendicular to db
so ac
is perpendicular to was it two
two ac is particularly db
to segment db and it's come straight out
of point it comes straight out of point
12. and we're done we've done a two
column proof and we have proven that
this line segment right over here is
perpendicular to that line segment right
over there we did it with sss with the
sss postulate and the side angle side
postulate